europium is an element which when you
excite the atoms or excite the electrons
in the atoms gives out very nice red
colored light okay so you wrote p.m. is
pretty much in the middle of the
lanthanide series and apps it's most
famous use is in television screens in
fact most or many of the rare earths can
fluoresce in this way and give out light
but your opium is particularly good at
giving a very nice red color and so you
rope your salts are used in television
screens not LCD screens like you have on
a laptop but the old-fashioned cathode
ray M televisions so it's very good a
phosphorescence for example so we use it
in the tubes
in TV screens to get different colors
the screen on the inside of the screen
you have dots of europium and when the
electrons from the electron beam in the
cathode ray tube hit the europium you
get a very intense Domitian of red light
which gives you the red color to form
the color television pictures